jean d'ormesson
1 tu utilisé sa notoriété pour séduire
je crois que me suis servi des femmes
pour être connu ouais et ensuite je me
suis servi ce que j'étais connu pour
avoir des femmes à jean d'ormesson
as-tu consommer des substances
aphrodisiaques
hélas un visa mans jean d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher en accomplissant l'acte
d'amour sans volonté de procréer
c'est ce qu'il faut dire la vérité
bah au jugement dernier oui jean
d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher à la mouche à la bouche
jean d'ormesson as tu envie d'une jeune
cousine oui secret défense
jean d'ormesson as-tu plus durant son
existence à la communauté homosexuelle
grâce à dieu
oui comment je me rappelle que l'asie
racontant d'entre nous cette entrevue
non moi je ne voulais pas ruiner d'un
coup tout le capital de sympathie que je
me suis attirée je ne suis pas
homosexuel mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup
plus à les homosexuels qui ont été les
amis très chers à moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
et quelques fois j'ai été obligé de
courir un peu dans la salle de bain et
l'auto de ou autour de la cuisine s'est
arrêté là jean d'ormesson
as tu regardé tf1 samedi soir
il m'est même arrivé de regarder
thalassa
il est arrivé tout regard des gens
dorment son insu déjà eu envie de te
suicider
je me suis toujours arrêtée sur cette
pente parce que je pense que le suicide
ratée est une chose très ridicule
jean d'ormesson as tu déjà cru que dieu
n'existait pas pire quelques fois je me
suis allé jusqu'à croire qu'il existait
jean d'ormesson as-tu commis le péché de
mensonges en répondant à ces questions
oui bien sûr je testais menti j'en
appelle à l'assistance
l'enfer ou le paradis parfait